your fav celeb couples work cupcaking
all weekend meanwhile things got serious
between me and some tacos last night
hi friend
I've got no shame welcome to the daily
Denny now I know you guys had a good
weekend just looking at our new music
Friday poll because we had over a
thousand votes and 56% of y'all were
fill in that future and nici track you
to baddest
which means I know you were jam in and
you weren't alone Jennifer Lopez and
Alex Rodriguez were serving straight
weekend vibes
check out these lovebirds Cruz in and a
Rob's car lets you know about it
[Music]
I'm still good for four but they are
quickly becoming my fave celebrity
couple that means that they are still
not John and Chrissie level you know
like I'm giving that in that moment and
eight point five on the John and
Chrissie scale because Iran is in
swooning enough I know you're driving
sir but JLo is vibing you look bored
meanwhile Britney Spears and her
boyfriend actor model Sam asked Gauri
are over here being silly in this very
colorful clip Britt Britt posted on
Saturday goofing around with her man it
looks mean but here's my hot tank are we
buying this relationship there's a
little to Instagram perfect to me and I
say this because I have Brittany's best
interests at heart and I'm afraid he's
over here collecting followers and likes
which is why I'm giving them a 6 on the
John and Chrissy scale I'm sorry there's
no time to move up guys don't worry but
you know someone down for curves in all
the edges is Liam Hemsworth the Aussie
was just snapped sharing a passionate
kiss with rebel Wilson no Liam is not
leaving Miley for rebel the coast stars
are on the set of their new comedy isn't
it romantic and nothing screams romance
like a green screen people meanwhile
Blake Lively is opening up to Glamour
magazine about life at home with her
hubby Ryan Reynolds and their two
daughters and it's not what you expect
Blake shoots down the perception that
she has a perfect life by saying she
loves Ryan most of the time I'm sorry
well apparently she tells the mad quote
if I say I'm so in love with him all the
time then you get that eye rolling often
life is so great she's so perfect so
it's like my defense mechanism okay okay
I got cheer that is fair Blake but let
me remind you your man is fine and funny
as hell which is why he is the perfect
Deadpool and thankfully some fans up
there
today Ryan tweeted a first look at Z
beef abdominal in the sequel writing
some people just know how to work a red
carpet now the photo is totally a call
back to that first photo of Ryan
soon except this time looks like he
might have finally met his match in
Domino because she looks pretty badass
to me but I want to know what do you
guys think of Z Z as Domino you know the
deal let us know in the comments section
below
alright from one fierce female in the
Marvel Universe to another each II spoke
to the stars of Captain Marvel brie
Larson and samuel l.jackson within hours
of each other on Sunday and each actor
gave us a little taste of what we can
expect from the upcoming movie of course
if seeing the success of Wonder Woman in
the DC Universe does that make you more
excited about it you feel more pressure
less pressure I feel pressure in that
it's a it's a character that people love
and are inspired by and I see that and
so I want to do right by that and I want
people to feel like their character is
honored but from the like female
standpoint I don't understand why
there's like pressure put on women as if
it's like the most like shocking concept
ever that a woman can open a movie is
like it's kind of a tired concept so
he's proved it for a long time so I
don't feel pressure that way at all it
has been confirmed and we just spoke to
brie that you will be in the Captain
Marvel film very excited to hazard oh ok
exist in the 90s yeah so what are you
most excited about doing that film and
playing necklace you know where you
freeze like awesome reason that girl
sadly we've got to wait until 2019 for
Captain Marvel but something tells me it
will be worth the wait
speaking of fans of Game of Thrones had
the wait seven seasons before two
beloved characters in the series finally
got to meet now if you know me then you
know I've literally only watched one
episode of Game of Thrones ever that's
why our girl Leanne Aguilera is here for
a quick recap of Sunday night's episode
what's on Danni talk to me okay for a
present like me outside of this world I
feel like everyone is always losing
their minds watching the show while I
was last night such a big deal last
night was a huge field any because for
the first time ever Daenerys Targaryen
and Jon Snow came face to face but
believe it or not that was the least
exciting part of the episode it was all
about watching some amazing ladies get
revenge on Reba we first watched Cersei
get revenge because her daughter was
last season and she killed a Lori's
daughter in the exact same way that
Marcella was killed
vicious girl vicious also Elena Tyrell
was sentenced to death but she went out
on top she confessed to Jamie that she
killed his own son Joffrey oh yes
it's amazing it's an epic moment no it
doesn't make any sense I'm gonna have to
take your words right before all you
diehard fans out there though this
morning Lee and dropped a new episode of
our Game of Thrones recap show Westeros
weekly wind special guests better call
Saul Patrick Fabian y'all breaking down
a very important theory we are okay so
once again this is not going to make any
sense to you but we have Thrones fans
out there you know that Cersei has a
prophecy and it was predicted that she
will die at the hands of one of her
brothers and we talked with Nikolaj
coster-waldau about whether or not he
thinks this theory could be true sure ah
no Coulomb sorry yes are you guys you
can catch that new episode it's up on
ETS YouTube channel now Thank You Mara
Thank You Jenny
all right that's it for today but we are
continuing the fun over on the community
tab so be sure to subscribe to our
channel because as you can tell there is
plenty to discuss
you can also visit ET online.com for all
these stories and a whole lot more talk
to you guys soon bye